تمت استعدادات شملت حتى النساء في بغداد
ليس بهدف الذهاب الى الجبهه الاماميه
وانما تحسبا للوقوع اسوا سيناريو محتمل
وهو دخول داعش الى العاصمه بغداد وبالتالي
ايقاض الخلايا النائمه التي يخشاها الجميع
ومن ثم ترك النساء عرضه للخطر
علياء البالغه من العمر 47 عاما هي احد
المتدربات اذ تقول انهم اصيبوا بالذعر
عندما راوا ما حدث للموصل مضيفه ان رجالهم
توجهوا للجبهه الاماميه وبالتالي ترك امر
الدفاع عن المنازل والنساء والاطفال للناس
انفسهم ابنه علياء البالغه من العمر 25
عاما موجوده هنا كذلك وهما تغطيان وجهيهما
لكي لا تكشف هويتهما امام الكاميرا
من قبل فيلق بدر الذي تدرب سابقا في ايران
لقتال نظام الرئيس الراحل صدام حسين
والتدريب الذي يستمر لمده خمسه ايام لنحو
20 الى 30 سيده
جيد يتضمن عقد دورات لامور اساسيه وهذه
ليست مهاره رغبنا بالحصول عليها لكن ظروف
البلد وكثره القتال يتطلب ذلك ويمنحهن
الشعور بالقوه قليلا ويلاحظ جليا معرفتهن
لمعنى خساره احد الاحباء
كالعاده
فوالد هاجر وشقيقها قتل خلال اربعين يوما
فقط في السنوات الاولى من الحرب ومنذ ذلك
الحين تطورت الاوضاع في البلاد الى ما
نراه اليوم